hôm nay, đồng thời chỉ đạo vợ là buổi thiết kým tuyên
ký hấp đồng tíu tụi sản phẩm.
Bản hân doy là họ sẽ hiểu các cân như tụi phía bốc tí tóc
với lệ người, theo dõi, rất là nhiều.
Tại vì chuyên tíng giói mặt hàng đã sản đêm mắt,
có nhập thì châu, nhập khẩu, của công ty, hoàn nạn,
công bố, là thị trâu, tây cây,
nhưng mà tôi, tế mắt, tụi đồng tíng,
thành thị trâu, các mép đã sản đêm mắt.
Để mong là mọi người, ủ hộ.
Tại vì các bạn đều tra bức đồng sắc định,
từ năm 2020, 2020,
tuyên đã mua sản phẩm, thị trâu, sĩ khô tây cây,
của công ty hoàn nằm, với tổng số tiền 8 mươi tìa đồng để bán.
Cung vuaan, buổi thị kiểm tuyên 8 m彩 mệt tảm tội
và phản văn 2, 4 mụi tội,
giám đốc công ty hoàn nằm, bị bắt tạm dạm về tội,
vì phản quy định về công tát ký tóan, ký hợp hoảng nghiêm trọng.